I already liked the way Disney does things with properties.
And it's worrying that they're acquiring so much that they have so much control
of the things because yeah, Disney movie is streamlined and it's nice,
but you don't, you don't get the weird from Disney. That's what I'm saying.
Like, when I, when I heard about that supposedly room moral,
whatever it was like, I wasn't like immediately, Oh, that's.
That's never going to happen because there is a very likely chance.
It very much might happen. Yeah. And if it does happen,
then it's going to be really bad for animate.
Like anime is going to get boring when that happens. I mean,
what I was saying now is that,
so like we can basically break down like the main plays to be Crunchyroll.
Funimation Netflix of like punchline Funimation and Netflix and you know,
there's, you know, central, I feel most soon doing their own thing. Yeah.
But I will say that the, putting those two together,
like they do have very different brands like this, you know,
sometimes you watch an anime and you're like, yeah, this seems,
this feels like a Netflix show.
I mean like B stars felt like it belonged on Netflix dev Mac fly,
maybe felt like it belonged on Netflix.
What I would say when it was like crunchy roll versus Funimation is that they
have like exact same branding. So I'm just like, Oh,
Cargill has Cargill summer's on French road then on Funimation like what?
Like season two's on fundamentals. Like I, you know,
cause like they were both trying to acquire the same show. It's it's,
it's the same type of consumers.
I feel that use both Funimation and crunch roll. And you know,
not to say that crunch all users don't use Netflix and vice versa,
but I feel that like, yeah, as you said, there's like a certain,
I don't know what the right word for it is. Edginess.
When it comes to shows on Netflix, I don't,
I don't know what the right word for it is. Is that,
that cooler older brother who comes in and is like, Hey,
you ever played a game boy like that? You know what I mean?
Like that vibe we've all seen. We've obviously done work with Netflix.
So this is totally like separated from, from that. But I mean,
that service is the best man. Like, I mean, you, you, I mean,
obviously the Netflix jail stuff sucks sometimes at least in Japan,
the subtitle differences. Again, those, we obviously know that sucks,
but I mean, you use that player and it's like, you can't beat that shot. No,
you can download it. And now you can do audio only on, uh, on the mobile,
which I love. Cause you used to have to keep,
when I used to listen to stuff on Netflix,
I used to have to keep my phone open in my pocket, like the screen going,
but now you can just do audio only. And it's like, Oh my God. It's like,
they know what I want. The question is then what would you watch?
What kind of content would work for audio? Only stuff like documentaries.
It's just like sometimes right? I'm like,
I'm in a situation where I couldn't do that for anime.
I'm in a situation where I can't look at my screen for like just two minutes.
Yeah. But cause I'm like, maybe I'm getting off the train.
Maybe I'm walking around real quick. I just want to,
I just want to lock my phone, but I want to keep listening.
It's got my headphones on.
So just quick little moments where you just want to turn it off,
but you don't want like content to just stop. Right? Right. Honestly,
the big thing for me for Netflix is, uh, the skip opening button.
Skip openings also just added the two times. Speed. One five. So now you can,
if you want to be a bastard more channel. Yeah. I know.
It's so Cardinal sin to say you could skip opening anime openings,
but that's,
that's made it so much more easier to watch some of the anime because let's be
honest. Let's be honest what you do automatically for endings. Yeah.
Yeah. Cause every time the great pretend to end it. I'm like, no, no, no. Yeah.
Sometimes you do watch the ending and sometimes you do listen to the opening,
but let's be honest. Most of the time you skip the,
you want to skip the opening.
You watch the opening once and it's another generic Jason
[inaudible] and I love bingeing anime. I don't watch anime weekly. So for me,
like, unless it's a banger of an opening,
which is there's always one or two shows every season,
but it's like every be stars was one.
Like I always with amazing opening mob, psycho as well.
Don't skip it. Just leave it. Just leave it Netflix. Come on. Just let it flow.
I want to watch this. Yeah, that's great. Yeah. Like, like you said, like, uh,
the great pretender ending, which is like you've,
you've always got time for Freddie mercury. Come on. You've always got done.
Never skip for anymore time. Is it? I've got time regardless.
You know what I mean? And you can download episodes.
I know you can do that crunchy roll. Now you can do,
you can pay extra to download a crunch roll. I have never tried it.
So I don't know how good the services, um,
cause I know you can do on Funimation but it didn't work that good.
That was like always the biggest complaint foundation.
I just said that the website was garbage. Yeah. As far as I know, I mean,
I would a knock on, you said don't live in the U S what do you, what do you,
what do you think the plan is with Sony?
Like why do you think they decided that's a good question.
That's what I've always wanted to know again. Right? It's like what,
what is it about Crunchyroll? And Funimation that's Sonny was like,
Sony drove a billion bucks on this study. He has a movie division. That's right.
I make a big branch, a big part of that business.
So do you think we'll start to see like maybe like funding, Sony,
original anime on control inflammation? Maybe. I dunno. Like,
cause they have to compete with Netflix originals, right? Yeah.
I mean right now,
I mean Sony kind of Sonya already on like the production committee to a
lot of anime cleaning, like big enemies.
Like I th I think isn't it like the demon Slayer. Oh yeah.
They think they're funny demon slab. Cause that's yeah. I actually,
I might be talking to my office. The, which company does Sony own.
Is it anyplace? [inaudible]
I'm pretty sure it's very shiny. The place was with Damon Slayer. Yeah.
They usually with like the majority of the big shown in,
or then it only make sense that they'd want to get a big grip on the Western
market. I mean, if you're, if you're funding this,
you already have a lot of say. Hmm. I mean, I,
I think right now I don't know what their plans are,
but I think the amount of money they throw at it just shows how much potential
they see for the anime market. Right? Yeah. For real,
it's a gold rush right now.
I think really like I think all of the companies have vibe like fighting to get
control over the Western market. Cause they realized like this big,
it's like an IP race. Right. [inaudible] essentially,
while it's still young and it still isn't fully settled. Right.
Which is now like,
why wouldn't you just throw money at the and try and get y'all, you know,
don't get all the IPS get older. I mean,
D do you see like animate becoming as big as say like gaming or like other
things? Yeah. Maybe. Maybe not like and Thai, but yeah.
Maybe, maybe not, man. Hey man. You just wait, you just wait boy, you just wait,
you just wait,
you just wait until I drop my original hand tie and then we'll see how big it
is. But listen, listen. Right. Everyone watches porn, right? Yeah.
But there isn't no like Avengers of porn.
No one's discussing like there's no podcasts about porn. I don't think actually,
maybe there's, you know, there's no,
there's a big discussions about porn and like, Oh my God. What's what's who,
whose ex who's Johnny, scene's gonna next. Johnny.
Johnny seems the captain America or porn.
It's not going to be that God get your hopes down now. Right?
I mean there's no man. Isn't like porn hub. One of what? Like in like the top 20
[inaudible] 60% of their libraries.